Lea Michele and robert buckley break up  after only two months of dating sources  confirmed to ET on Thursday that the  scream queen star and the eyes zombie  star have called it quits the  short-lived romance comes just days  after the couple was seen taking a  splash in a pool together over the July  4th weekend a source told ET back in May  that the two met through mutual friends  and were quote totally crazy about each  other  I've never been happier in my whole life  that same month Lea couldn't stop  blushing when we asked her about the  Paris new romance at the box upfront in  New York City you know I'm just feeling  really great right now and super happy  it feels very very very lucky and  grateful in my life right now and that's  all that matters the exes are still set  to star opposite each other in the  upcoming series dimension 404